>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> We have our next author
coming up to the stage.
And his name is Chris Van Dusen.
He's an author and an illustrator.
And when Chris Van Dusen was a
kid, he drew and drew and drew.
He especially liked to draw things
like aliens, robots, and monsters.
Two of his childhood heroes
were authors and illustrators
of children's books: Dr.
Seuss and Robert McCloskey.
Little did Chris know that one day
he, himself, would be an author
and an illustrator of
many children's books.
You might recognize his artwork
from the incredibly
popular Mercy Watson series.
He's here today to talk about
his new book, Hattie and Hudson,
a story about the unlikely
friendship between a little girl
and one of Mr. Van Dusen's
childhood specialties, a monster.
He will sign copies of his new
book from 11:30 to 12:30 PM
over there, in that direction.
Please make some noise
for Chris Van Dusen.
[ Applause ]
>> Chris Van Dusen: Hi, guys.
How are you?
Thanks for coming today.
I am so excited to
be -- oh, thank you.
That'd be good since I left
mine back at the hotel.
I'm going to set these -- I guess
I can put those right there.
Well, good morning, everybody.
Thanks for coming out today.
This is great!
I like the bean-bag idea.
It's kind of like a child
mosh-pit-type thing.
Isn't it? I like that a lot.
My name is Chris.
I live in Maine.
And I'm going to start, actually,
kind of go off script here
and I would feel bad if I
didn't sort of give a shout-out
to the people in Texas who are going
through this horrible
time, as you all know.
I mean just seeing
the things on the TV.
All the amount of rain
those people are having.
It's just unbelievable.
Up in Maine, what we do
is a lot of times we sort
of convert rain amounts
to snow amounts.
And it turns out to be
approximately like one inch
of rain equals a foot of snow.
So if Harvey had come to Maine and
sort of churned around the Gulf
of Maine for a week, like it
did off the coast of Texas,
we would have had about 48
feet of snow in our town.
And all you would see
is a big pile of snow
with a church steeple
sticking up because I live
in a little town on
the coast of Maine.
But that just seems
so absurd, right?
And it's because the
amount of rain they got
down there was just unbelievable.
So I hope the recovery goes well.
I really feel bad for those people.
Before I left Maine yesterday, I
heard on the news that in Portland,
which is the largest city in Maine,
they put a great big tractor-trailer
truck right in the middle
of Monument Square, which is
right in the middle of the city,
and they just opened up the
back, because it was empty,
and they just encouraged people
to come and just put stuff
in the tractor trailer
for the people of Texas.
So I hope by now that that
truck is pretty well filled up.
All right.
So let's talk about books.
That's why we're here.
Right? So I'm an author/illustrator
of children's picture books.
You guys may know that.
I actually started my career
by being an illustrator.
Do you -- all you kids
know what an illustrator --
who can raise their hand and
tell me what an illustrator does?
What does an illustrator do?
[Inaudible] That's right:
someone who draws pictures.
It's really just kind of a
fancy name for someone who gets
to stay home and draw pictures all
day long, because that's what I do.
I stay home, at home,
and I just draw pictures,
usually in my slippers, and I
just draw pictures all day long.
I get to draw the coolest pictures.
But I didn't start writing books
until quite a few years later.
So I started out as an illustrator
and then years later I
started doing the writing.
And I did a lot of illustrations
for all sorts of magazines.
That's what most of my
work was: for magazines.
And I noticed the type of magazines
I really loved illustrating
for were kids' magazines,
because those are the magazines
I could do these crazy,
outlandish illustrations.
Kind of cartoony, which
is what I like.
And I just loved illustrating
for the kids' magazines.
Well, one day I was in my studio and
I was working on an illustration,
and this image popped into my head.
And I don't know why
this popped in my head,
but it was a very vivid
image that had to come out.
And the picture that I
pictured in my head was of a man
in a little motorboat with his dog
and they were stuck way
up in the top of a tree.
And I don't know why that popped
in my head, but I thought,
"That would be really fun to draw."
And so I grabbed a scrap of paper
and I quickly drew this little man
in his boat on the top of a tree.
And I set it aside and
I went back to work.
So I'm working away
on my illustration.
I kept looking over
at that illustration,
that little sketch
I did and I thought,
"I want to know more about that man.
I want to know more about who he
is, how he ended up in the top
of the tree, how he got there,
how is he going to get down?"
And so for the next few hours, the
next few days, the next few weeks,
I thought about that little picture
that I did, and nine years later,
that little sketch evolved into
my first book which was called
Down to the Sea with Mr. Magee.
Has anybody ever seen that book?
Some of you guys have seen that?
Oh, awesome!
I didn't think anybody outside
of Maine had heard of
that book actually.
But anyway, that was my first book.
When it came out I wasn't sure
I was going to do another book.
I wasn't sure if it
was going to be a dud
or if people were going
to actually like it.
And so I went back to doing
magazine illustration.
But I guess it did well enough
because the publisher asked me
if I'd like to do another
Mr. Magee book.
And so I wrote a book about
Mr. Magee going camping
and that's called A Camping
Spree with Mr. Magee.
Has anybody seen --
you seen that one?
Yeah? Okay.
Wow. That -- see I -- that
kind of blows me away.
I just didn't know you guys
would know those books.
Because I'm probably best known,
one of my best-known books is
a book called The Circus Ship.
You guys seen this one?
[Applause] So The Circus Ship
came out in 2009, it was published
by Candlewick Press, and it was
loosely based on a true story.
Off the coast of Maine where I live,
and I live about mid-coast Maine,
there were two big islands.
One's called Vinalhaven;
one's called North Haven.
And there really was a ship carrying
a circus in 1836 that sank --
Circus Ship, love it --
off the coast of Maine.
Right off the coast
from where I live.
And I read about it in a magazine,
and it really fascinated me
that there was an elephant swimming
around in Penobscot Bay
about 175 years ago.
And that's right --
that's where our harbor
in our town is, right
on Penobscot Bay.
And I thought, "That is so cool."
So I kind of logged it in
the back of my head somewhere
because I wasn't -- even at that
point I wasn't even writing books.
But eventually it sort
of popped back out
and that became The Circus Ship.
But I have to be honest,
I'm probably best-known
for being an illustrator of a series
of books about a little pig --
or not a little pig
actually a pretty big pig --
that causes a lot of havoc in a
neighborhood called Deckawoo Drive.
And those are called
the Mercy Watson books.
Anybody seen the Mercy Watson books?
[Cheering] Alright, now, I can only
claim the visual part of this book
because as you guys probably
know, this is written
by the amazing Kate
DiCamillo who's out here.
And I'm basically the warm-up act
for Kate because she comes on next.
So I'll get you guys
all prepped for Kate.
But yeah, those were great.
These were really fun to illustrate.
And the way these came about
is kind of a funny story.
The art director at Candlewick
Press, her name is Ann Stott,
that's the art director I work
with, she had my first three books.
She had the Down to the Sea with
Mr. Magee, she had A Camping Spree
with Mr. Magee and my third book
was a book called If I Built a Car.
So she had all those.
Thank you, I like a little
shout-out for -- that's great.
So she had those books and what she
would do, and I didn't know this
until years later, but she would go
to the editorial meetings and that's
where the editors and the art
directors get together and they try
to figure out what illustrators are
going to illustrate these books.
So she would come into the
meetings with the Mr. Magees
and If I Built a Car and she really
wanted to work with me on a project.
So they'd present some story or some
manuscript and Ann would say "Well,
how about Chris for this?"
And they'd say "No,
he's not quite right."
So the next manuscript would come,
she says "How about Chris for this?"
"No, that's not quite right."
Well, finally, I guess this
went on for weeks, months,
and finally the manuscript
came in from Kate DiCamillo
and it was called Mercy
Watson to the Rescue.
And Ann tried one more time,
she said "How about
Chris for these series?"
And I think really she
just kind of wore them out.
I think she just wanted them -- you
know, they just wanted her to shut
up about Chris Van Dusen.
So they said "okay, we'll
give Chris Van Dusen a shot."
And so I got a call from an art
director I had never heard of,
from a publisher I never
worked for, and said "would you
like to illustrate a series
of books by Kate DiCamillo?"
And it was kind of like someone just
came to my door riding a unicorn
with a pot of gold basically.
Because that's what it felt.
It felt so magical.
And so for the next four years
of my life, and this is what it's
like being an illustrator.
You get a call one day
and someone says "Hey,
how about for the next four years
of your life you paint
nothing but pig pictures?
Sometimes they're in pink dresses."
And you go, "I'm your man.
Sign me up."
And so that's what I did
for the next four years,
I did pig pictures
for the Mercy Watson.
By the way, there are about
50 illustrations in each one
of these books and there are six
books in the original series.
So that's about 300 paintings,
that's why it took
me about four years.
So. But the book we're talking about
today, and I haven't even gotten
to it yet, is my latest book.
It's called Hattie and Hudson.
Has anybody seen this book yet?
Some of you guys have?
Oh, excellent.
So this came out in May
and it's a different book
for me for two main reasons.
The first reason is,
it's not a rhyming story.
All the books I've written up to
this point are rhyming stories.
I mean, the Mercy Watsons
aren't but I didn't write those.
But The Circus Ship and the Mr.
Magee books, the If I Built books,
King Hugo's Huge Ego, Randy
Riley's Really Big Hit,
they're all rhyming books.
If I Built a House.
And so this is the first
time I've written a book
in prose instead of verse.
It's also the first
book I've written
where a girl is the main character.
Right, girls?
[Cheering] Little fist
pump for girls.
And the reason I did this because
I go around to schools mostly
up in Maine where I live
and I talk to the kids.
And a lot of kids were starting
to give me some flak,
especially little girls.
And I was telling Kate
this story yesterday.
At one school I was at, I probably
shouldn't have done this but I did,
this little girl raised her hand
after my presentation and she said,
"Are you ever going to write a book
with a girl as a main character?"
And she kind of caught me off guard
and I didn't quite know what to say
and I said, "Well, um, hmm, uh,
well, uh, Mercy Watson's a girl."
And the girl looked at me, I mean,
I think she almost put her hands
on her hips and went
"Mercy Watson's a pig."
And I said, "Oh yeah, you're right."
And the teacher helped me
out, she kind of stepped in.
She said, "But technically, you
didn't write those books, right?"
And I said, "Yes, that's right.
I didn't write those books,"
which had kind of saved me.
So this is the first
book with a girl.
It didn't start that way.
It actually started
like all my other books.
It started with a boy, and it
started out as a rhyming book.
It was a boy called Henry and
the title was Henry and Hudson
because I liked the idea sort of
playing with the name Henry Hudson.
And it was a rhyming story.
But it just wasn't working.
I tried over and over and over
again to make the story work,
and it just was going nowhere.
My editor Joan Powers was
a little lukewarm on it.
My agent Steve Malk, he was
a little lukewarm about it.
I was a little lukewarm about it.
And I couldn't figure out
why it wasn't working.
And finally one morning I
woke up and it was almost
like the book was talking,
the story was talking to me.
And it said, "I don't want
to be a rhyming story.
I don't want to be a rhyming story.
Write me in prose."
And so I said, "Of course!"
So I sent an email to my editor,
Joan, and I said, "You know,
I think this story is trying
to tell me it doesn't
want to be rhyming story."
And she said, "Why don't
you take a page and write it
in prose, and send it to me?"
So I did and I sent it
to her later that day
and she mailed me a note right back
and she said, "This
is so much better.
Why don't you just write
the whole story in prose?"
So I did. So I wrote the whole story
and I worked really hard at it.
And I kept it very simple, very
minimal, and I sent it off to her.
And she hated it.
She absolutely hated it.
I remember I kind of moped
around the house for a few days,
and my wife, you know, was kind
of looking at me like, "Oh, geez.
Here we go."
And my son said, "What's
up with dad?"
And my wife said, "It's kind like
he just got an F on a paper."
And so I went and what I had
done is I had taken out all sort
of the details, all the things
that made it really sort of fun.
And so Joan said, "You got to put
those things back in, you know.
You can't make it so bare-bones.
You really have to sort of add those
details that give it the flavor."
So that's what I did.
So I don't -- do you
mind if I read it?
Can I read the story?
It's kind of small.
[Applause] It's kind of small,
and you probably won't
see the pictures too well,
but at least you'll get
an idea of the story.
And then we'll have some
questions after that.
"Hattie McFadden loved to explore.
Every morning after breakfast,
she'd grab her lifejacket,
wave goodbye to her parents
and paddle out in the canoe
to see what she could see.
Hattie discovered all kinds
of things out of the lake.
She watched as a beaver
tugged an alder branch slowly
through the water.
Above, two bald eagles circled round
and round on wings brought in flat.
And over the cove,
a family of turtles
with shiny black shells
basked in the warm summer sun.
Hattie was so happy
she started singing.
'When the sun is up and the day
is new and the birds are a-singing
in the sky, that's when you'll
find me in my little canoe.
Paddle just a-paddling by.'
She had no idea she was being heard.
Down at the bottom of the
lake in a cave dark and deep,
there lived a mysterious creature.
He was enormous but elusive.
He never ventured up to the surface.
He spent his days down below,
all alone and out of sight.
The monster was used to
hearing motors buzzing
and propellers churning overhead.
It was why stayed hidden
in his cave.
But today he heard
something different.
A song, bouncy and bubbly, came
echoing down through the water.
'So come with me because
there's room for two.
We'll be together, you and I.
Out on the lake in my little canoe.
Paddle just a-paddling by.'
It was so cheerful and
charming that it drew the beast
out of his lair and
up toward the light.
He broke through the water, drawn
by the music and there just off
to his right, was a young girl
alone in a canoe, singing.
Hattie stopped when the
thing rose beside her.
She stared at the monster
and the monster stared back.
But she didn't feel afraid.
There was something in his eyes.
The way he looked at her and
the curious tilt of his head.
It was almost as if he
wanted to hear more.
So Hattie softly continued singing.
'When the sun goes down and the day
is through and the moon is arise
in the sky, I'll take you
home in my little canoe.
Paddle just a-paddling by.'
And as she sang the last
note, Hattie was astounded
when the giant joined in,
harmonizing with a low rumble."
It sounded like this.
"Then someone screamed.
People pointed.
Some fainted.
Motors roared as boats
fled in a frenzy.
Amid all the commotion, the
creature slid beneath the water
and Hattie paddled slowly and
silently back to the dock.
That night, Hattie tried to sleep
but every time she closed her eyes,
she pictured the green, friendly
face looking down at her.
She wondered if she'd
ever see him again.
She decided she had to find out.
At the bottom of the lake, the
girl's sweet song played over
and over in the monster's head.
He wondered if he'd
ever see her again.
He decided he had to find out.
Hattie paddled the canoe
quietly through the darkness.
She stopped, waited and looked
down into the rippling water.
Suddenly, a massive black
shape emerged from the depths.
Two glowing eyes grew
brighter and brighter
as the shape drew closer and closer.
Slowly, the gigantic head
emerged from the water.
It glistened in the moonlight.
For a moment or two, the monster
and the girl simply
stared at each other.
Then Hattie broke the silence.
'Hi, I'm Hattie,' she said,
'the girl you met this morning.
I was really hoping
I'd see you again.
What's your name?'
The monster cocked his head.
'You do have a name, don't you?'
The monster raised his eyebrows
and cocked his head even more.
'Hmmm. Maybe you don't,'
Hattie said.
'Well, you kind of remind
me of my uncle's dog Hudson.
Maybe I should call you Hudson.
Do you like that name?
Hudson?' The monster slowly smiled.
'Good. I like it, too,' she said.
'It fits you.
Hello, Hudson.'
And just like that, they
became fast friends.
The little girl and the huge
monster splashed and played
in the silvery moonlight
until Hattie realized it
was time to head home.
As she climbed into the canoe, she
turned around smiling and said 'Hey,
Hudson, let's meet again
tomorrow night, okay?'
Hudson nodded eagerly
and smiled back.
The next afternoon, there was
a meeting at the town hall.
Everyone was yelling,
suggesting ways to get rid
of what they called
'the deadly beast.'
If only they knew him,
Hattie thought.
She tried to say something,
but she was interrupted.
She tried again but
no one heard her.
She tried several times to speak.
Finally, she gave up.
When the meeting was over,
Hattie walked home with her dad.
She felt a little sick.
Hattie snuck out again that night to
be with Hudson, but when they met,
she didn't feel much like playing.
'The townspeople saw you
yesterday,' she explained.
'Everyone thinks you're dangerous.
Tomorrow they're coming to
catch you and take you away.
I don't know where to, but
we can't let this happen.
We need a plan.'
Hattie was deep in thought when
Hudson abruptly nudged the canoe
with his nose, nearly
knocking it over.
'Hey!' barked Hattie.
Hudson did it again.
'What the heck?'
Once again, he bumped
the boat then he looked
at her and smiled brightly.
'Wait a second.
I think I know what
you're doing,' said Hattie.
Then she added, 'and
this could work.
This could definitely work.
Hudson, you're a genius!'
At the break of dawn, Hattie paddled
her canoe over to the town landing.
The men were already
gathered, loading their boats
with radars, ropes and netting.
Hattie started to feel sick again.
But she had to stay focused.
She had to stick to the plan.
She had to save her new friend.
So she paddled her canoe
away from the shore
and to the center of the lake.
Then, she waited.
Now it was Hudson's turn.
He swam up to Hattie.
He carefully bumped the
bottom of the canoe,
it flipped over easily tossing
Hattie, as planned, into the water.
Hattie flailed her arms, she
waved, she splashed the water.
She pretended to be
in serious peril.
The men on the landing
sprang into action.
'Hang on!'
someone hollered.
'We're on our way!'
The boats were coming quickly
but Hattie waited and waited
until they were in perfect position,
then she signaled to Hudson."
And look at what you
have to do on this page.
You have to go like this.
You can see, if you look closely,
Hattie is sitting in the top
of Hudson's head, so that's kind
of like a fake rescue
that they've planned.
"The people stared in complete
stunned silence as Hudson swam past.
When he reached the landing,
he gently lowered his head
so Hattie could slide off.
Now, it was Hattie's
turn to hold a meeting.
'This is Hudson,' she said bravely.
'He's a friend of mine.
I know you think he's scary
and mean and dangerous,
but he's actually very friendly.
He won't hurt you, I promise.
This lake is his home, and
I think he deserves to stay.
Once you get to know him
I'm sure you'll agree.'
Hattie paused.
Everyone stood still.
Then a young boy slowly walked up
and patted Hudson gently
on the nose.
Another child followed,
then another.
Soon a few adults cautiously
stepped forward.
Before long, a crowd had
gathered around Hudson.
It took some convincing
but eventually everyone welcomed
the idea of having Hudson around.
He even became something
of an attraction.
People traveled from far
and wide to spend time
with the famous friendly monster.
But when the sun went down and
the visitors left, for Hattie
and Hudson everything was just as
it had been since the beginning.
And every night, they met in the
same place, played the same games,
and splashed and frolicked under
the big, silver summer moon."
[ Applause ]
Thank you, that's the story.
I just want to mention
a couple of things
and then we'll have some questions.
I just want to mention a
couple things about this book.
First of all, there is a
message of acceptance here,
of not judging by appearance.
But I started this book
way before the election.
I just want you to know that.
Because some of the reviews
have come out; they said,
"This message of acceptance is
so timely" and I started this
like way back in 2013 or something.
And but there is one
line in this book that,
thanks to our current
president, is so fitting,
I almost could've just said
"Muslim man" in the line
because it's almost
the exact same thing.
It's a line that says,
"This lake is his home
and I think he deserves to stay."
And I think that's a really
powerful line in the book.
So.
[ Applause ]
There is also -- I knew I could
say this because I think a lot
of you guys feel the same
way about this whole thing --
so anyway, there's also a
line in this book that --
I've worked with Kate DiCamillo
for so long that there's a line
that I swear it sounds like
something Kate would write,
and I want to just run it past you.
It's when Hattie's like pretending
to be in trouble and the line is,
"She pretended to be
in serious peril."
And I could've said, "She
pretended to be in trouble"
but for some reason, I just
put "serious peril" in there,
and after I wrote that I said,
"That's a line Kate
would write" right there.
So I think it's just
sort of rubs off a bit.
But anyway, so that's the new story
and I look like I'm just about out
of time, but maybe we have
time for a few questions,
and does anybody have
anything they'd like to ask?
I don't want to go over on my time.
Any questions?
I got one right here in the middle.
>> How did you get inspired?
>> Chris Van Dusen: Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Wait, hold on.
I'll get you next, yes.
Yep?
>> How did you get inspired
to write about a lake monster?
You could've like written
about a tree monster or --
>> Chris Van Dusen: Yeah!
>> Or based it away from the lake.
>> Chris Van Dusen:
That's a great question.
The reason I wrote about a lake
monster is I live near a big lake
in Maine.
There's a big lake in my town.
And it's a really deep lake
and I always sort of --
it's the lake that's sort
of pictured in this book.
And I've always sort of been
fascinated by lake monsters.
When I was a kid, the Loch
Ness Monster was really popular
and people were always finding new
pictures of the Loch Ness Monster.
And so I've always been
fascinated by lake monsters.
But originally I thought maybe the
monster would have a personality,
the monster would talk,
too, and all that.
But I decided to just abandon that
and just make the monster not talk
and just become a great friend
to this very brave girl.
And I think it's such a cool idea
to have like this huge friend.,
you know, living in the lake
that you could just
have so much fun with.
That's a great question.
We had a question right down here.
>> I'm so sorry.
>> Chris Van Dusen: That's okay.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
She said when you create a story,
did the pictures come first
or the words come first?
It kind of goes hand in hand when
you're working as an illustrator
because a lot of times
when I'm writing the story,
I do little thumbnail
sketches of what I sort
of picture would be on each spread.
But I really have to finish up
the story completely before I go
to the series of tight
sketches and final art, so.
We have one more question and
I think that's going to be it
because I'm being told
to wrap it up.
So, yes.
>> How did you make the pictures?
>> Chris Van Dusen: How
did I make the pictures?
That's a great question.
All my illustrations in all my
books are actually paintings.
They're painted with a
paint called gouache,
which some of you artists might
know, but kids always look at me
and think I'm saying "squash."
But it's actually gouache,
it's a water-based paint.
It's like an opaque watercolor and
I usually start with a background
and work to the foreground.
Takes me about two weeks
to do a typical spread
illustration for a book.
So altogether, a book can take like
seven, eight, nine, ten months.
The Circus Ship had
a lot of details,
that took me about 14 months
to paint those pictures.
I think we have to leave it there
because I don't want to bump
in on Kate's time and I
know she's here and waiting.
So thank you guys so much.
I really enjoyed it.
Have a great festival!
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.